Sylvester Stallone wrote this movie
that's right writer director actor
entrepreneur Stallone homefront
so Homefront's the story of Jason
Statham he's a former DEA agent he makes
a big bust in the beginning of the movie
now he's laying low in this really small
last town but James Franco and his crew
they're cooking up a meth operation down
there so now Jason Statham's gonna have
to go to work it's not even work cuz he
doesn't work for the DEA anymore so he's
gonna have to get the pleasure which
automatically you know it's fight time
these [ __ ] are stepping up to Jason
Statham at first he's like don't do this
but then they keep present him and stay
there just has to step back and he's
like no I was in the one with gently he
was the one so that kind of makes me - -
and he kicked some ass and the fights in
this movie they sound awesome they look
awesome it's every hit you feel every
bone that breaks you feel it every piece
of cartilage that rips you feel it head
goes through a piece of glass you feel
the impact and the shattered it's
everything I like about fights and
movies I like to feel it here which is
great for the few fights that happened
in the movie for the thirty seconds they
last rest of the movies just kind of
happening you can write it off as
character building if you want but in
the end I write it off as a lot of
people mean mugging Jason Statham as
he's walking down the street Jason
Statham picking up his little girl at
school Jason Statham building his deck
Jason Statham trying to be a good father
good for him and me sitting there kind
of bored in a movie written by Rambo
that concept baffles me be clear I don't
hate this entire movie there were things
in the movie I really liked like I said
the fights Jason Statham I like Jason
Statham he's a great action star who has
learned from the mistakes of other
action stars and he was like pacifier
Tooth Fairy not doing that that's right
I'm gonna stick to action I'm not gonna
branch out to other things I will stick
to action I will be typecast and I will
always have a paycheck good for him
James Franco is more or less the villain
or the [ __ ] in this movie and his
meth operations just they're just a
bunch of hillbilly dicks
there's nothing upper-class about it
they're all just shitty in their little
podunk town kate bosworth in the movie
this is what the movie did it made me go
oh she's a good actress I never thought
of Kate Bosworth as a good actress I
never really thought of Kate Bosworth at
all I saw her in this movie she's raging
out she's cracked out she's tweaking I
was like yes see kids this is what
happens to you
you're in a movie like Superman Returns
oh holy [ __ ] it's actually a roll it's
oh wow she's a good actress that's what
the movie taught me it's not a bad thing
no good job Kate Bosworth the movie does
uncomfortable really well there are a
couple of scenes for some of these
[ __ ] want to apply pressure to
someone so they move in close and doing
intimidation conversational tactics I
was like this is uncomfortable it's a
good job movie you're pulling that off
well so the movie did have good actors
doing a good job acting in the movie the
fights when they happen we're really
cool but a lot of this movie dragged on
you're just waiting for something to
happen nothing's happening it's not a
piece-of-shit movie you walk out
enjoying things in it in the end I got
to say homefront is probably a good time
if you're drunk yeah now it's a party
hey fighting no no they're not fighting
yet they're just talking so my question
to you what is your favorite Jason
Statham action movie whatever your
favorite is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you